but I first have to ask why do you think  it is that they hate you so much  I think it's a really big threat to them  when they see their own words being  being said and being spread the way that  that it is but no no I'm sorry that's  what I don't understand a person says a  thing and then you go hey look this  person said a thing and they're like  stop stop wait wait what well not just  that also they want to go viral on Tech  talk the reason they make tick tocks is  to go viral so they want these videos to  be shared and spread and they want a ton  of views but just not by us do you like  take it out of context and just post the  worst never I I I don't edit the videos  yeah do you just take like tiny clips of  longer videos and post like the most  only if it's like a 10 minute video